siempre me pregunte qué será emprender
habrá alguna receta mágica para lograr
el éxito y también me pregunte habrá
algún sabio que nos diga cuál será el
camino para emprender y finalmente me
dije ser es buena para yo ser
emprendedora y ahí es donde comienza mi
camino del emprendimiento y del
crecimiento personal porque había
escuchado que para ser buen emprendedor
había que ser mejor persona alguien ha
escuchado acá eso sí levanten la mano
que han escuchado y así que ahí fue
donde comienza mi búsqueda comienzo a
hacer cuanto curso había
y empiezo a leer todos los libros que
encontraba al que le pasó
hago charlas de motivación y un día casi
hablo hasta como extraterrestre
y allí me doy cuenta que emprender
no es
una moda es un estilo de vida y es el
estilo de vida que llevo hasta hoy día y
es parte de lo que les voy a compartir
la tarde de hoy
el 75% de las empresas de las pymes y de
los emprendedores los dos primeros años
fracasan y solamente el 20% de ellos
en los primeros en los cinco años
siguientes también fracasan y ahí es
donde me digo por qué está ocurriendo
esto qué pasa con los números de los
emprendedores porque no tenemos éxito y
una de las primeras respuestas era que
no nos preparábamos que no nos educamos
como emprendedores y es una de las cosas
por las cuales estoy acá y trabajo ahora
para mí el emprendimiento es un estilo
de vida como decía y además me ha hecho
descubrir dos cosas maravillosas que
seguramente a todos ustedes les ha
ocurrido y que hoy van a darse cuenta
que es así y que funciona
y esas dos cosas son la teoría de unir
los puntos de steve jobs y
la maravillosa palabra o el evento
serendipia
allí empieza mi primera historia de unir
los puntos
steve jobs cuenta que cuando deja la
universidad en su discurso de la
universidad de stanford cuenta que deja
la universidad y está totalmente perdido
alguien le ha pasado que ha dejado la
universidad y se siente como 20 años
allá y no sabe qué va a hacer con su
vida pues a él le pasó hasta que un día
encuentra un curso de caligrafía
imagínense ustedes steve jobs en un
curso de caligrafía así que desarrolla
este curso de caligrafía lo termina y
qué pasa con estilos
nada
es hasta cuando veinte años después diez
años después perdón crea la primera
macintosh y allí toda esta información
que ocurrió bajó y se dio cuenta y él
comentaba que si no hubiese sido por
este curso de caligrafía quizás nunca
aunque él lo asegura todas las
computadoras habrían tenido esa
maravillosa tipografía que hoy conocemos
y aquí comienza mi primera historia de
los puntos
hace aproximadamente nueve años conocí a
una familia argentina en venezuela en
esto que ven atrás es la isla de
margarita un hermoso lugar yo trabajaba
como productora de un programa de
deportes extremos y me tocaba ir en una
lancha a trabajar y necesitaba dejar
algunos equipos en la arena así que me
les acerco como pueden ver quizás y los
que me conocen se me da bien el hablar
así que me les acerco además tengo el
hábito de conocer gente nueva
me les acerque les digo que si por favor
me pueden sostener todas esas cosas que
tenía allí ellos accedieron después de
eso los invito a mi casa los invito a
conocer mi cultura mi espacio mi gente
que como todos los latinoamericanos
somos maravillosos y muy cercanos y todo
esto dura hasta que sus vacaciones
terminan
así que nunca perdimos el contacto
después de eso siempre me preguntaban
qué es mara es real lo que está
ocurriendo en tu país en el suelo y
lamentablemente para mí era cierto
lo que estaba ocurriendo en mi país así
que año tras año conversábamos
conversábamos hasta que un día me dicen
que sí por favor quiero emigrar que no
me preocupe que si quiero hacerlo
argentina ellos están totalmente a la
orden
siempre lo decían siempre lo decían
hasta que dos años después tomó la
decisión
y emigra
este dios dice que no pueden conectar
los puntos mirando hacia el futuro sólo
pueden hacerlo mirando hacia el pasado
por lo que tienen que confiar que los
puntos de alguna forma se conectarán en
su futuro tienen que confiar en algo
señor es su instinto el destino la vida
el karma lo que sea porque creyendo que
los puntos se conectarán en el camino te
dará la confianza de seguir tu corazón
incluso cuando te lleven fuera del
camino conocido y eso hará toda la
diferencia y esta es mi historia de
puntos donde que iba a imaginarme que en
ese momento que me les acerco a ellos
iba a estar ocho años después viviendo
en su casa siendo prácticamente una hija
más aunque ellos son muy jóvenes para
que no me vayan a regañar después así
que bueno llegó a este país maravilloso
la verdad que en argentina nos sentimos
los venezolanos muy cómodos aprovecho
para agradecerles
y empiezo mi primer trabajo y luego el
segundo y siempre el emprendedor y
seguramente les pasa lo que él emprende
no quieren emprender están a veces como
no quieren estar en su zona de confort y
es allí donde decido buscar un trabajo
otro hasta que un día en una reunión una
persona me comenta y me dice x mara hay
una radio importante en esta ciudad
donde muy probablemente por tu
currículum quieran contar contigo así
que ese mismo día señores dos horas
después me reúno con la directora de
esta radio y allí nace mi primer
programa de radio en argentina el arte
de emprender donde hasta el día de hoy
entrevistado especialista en
emprendimiento y emprendedores de más de
10 países quienes nos cuentan todo lo
que ocurre en el área del emprendimiento
a nivel mundial porque es un fenómeno
mundial el emprendimiento
y esta historia yo le llamo serendipia
sí porque porque la serendipia es un
descubrimiento que se logra de manera
casual e imprevista cuando en realidad
se estaba tratando de encontrar o de
conseguir algo diferente louis pasteur
destacó la importancia de la observación
acompañada del ingenio de la ciencia y
dice y dijo en el campo de la
observación
el azar solamente favorece a las mentes
preparadas así que señores tenemos que
estar y señores y señoritas preparados
para lo que viene tenemos que estar
buscando mucha gente dice que suerte
casualidad que tienes mucha suerte acaso
no es suerte es estar buscando lo que
queremos y solo allí si y sólo si va a
ocurrir este evento serendipia dos
maletas con poca ropa pero llenas de
muchísimos sueños así me vine a este
país
tengo 39 años imagínense emigrar a sus
39 años y les invito a que hagamos un
ejercicio
les voy a invitar a que cierren los ojos
un ejercicio de confianza
si él es ojo muy bien respiren profundo
y las que nunca han emigrado en su vida
imaginé que tienen que hacerlo y tienen
solo dos maletas frente a ustedes
y los que ya son inmigrantes cuando
estaban seleccionando cada una de sus
maletas que metían allí que estaba por
pasar allí
están en esa habitación con ustedes
mismos
seleccionando cada pieza que observan y
que van tomando para llenarla
que sienten porque esa pieza que están
tomando merece
que esté dentro de tu maleta
hay algo o alguien que te diga qué es lo
que tienes que llevar
y ahora observa esas dos maletas con
esas cosas
qué llevas por qué y sobre todo para qué
respiren profundo
muy bien pueden abrir los ojos
me encanta hacer este ejercicio porque
teniendo la edad que tengamos nos dice o
nos muestra lo que realmente es
importante para nosotros en este momento
lo decía uno de nuestros oradores
también que es importante para ustedes
en este momento
hace muchísimo tiempo quería estar en
una te de c's pero siempre me decía que
complicado x mari a mi país una locura
en este país en argentina nadie me
conoce
pero dije si lo quieres lo puedes lograr
y ahí ocurrió mi evento como se llama se
sentía muy bien lo pensaba y lo pensaba
y lo pensaba pero no estaba sentada
esperando me hice la tarea y me hice el
hábito de ver escuchen
una charla te o te decks todos los días
y es un hábito que tengo hace
aproximadamente tres años
hoy estoy acá frente a ustedes
estudiantes empresarios emprendedores
soñadores y una vez más mis dos palabras
y fenómenos acontecimientos como mejor
deseen llamarles está ocurriendo
nuevamente
la unión de los puntos hacia atrás de
steve jobs me fue poniendo a las
personas y en los momentos indicados
y la serendipia una vez más hizo su
magia y después de un largo año de
trabajo
estoy acá
hace aproximadamente bueno el año pasado
llevé a toda mi familia colombia pude
sacar los de venezuela
muy pronto para mí uniendo los puntos
hacia atrás me daré cuenta el por qué
ellos en colombia y yo en argentina
esto
respiro y seguramente en una charla te
des en las redes sociales desde ese país
ustedes pueden verme y decir guau esto
que keys mariah contaba era cierto
hoy todos nos iremos a nuestras casas
con
o sin nuestras cinco o con nuestras
familias y quizás
mañana pasado mañana en un mes en un año
tengan un evento serendipia
hay que estar muy despiertos para eso
pero de algo de lo que si esto todo
estoy totalmente segura pero totalmente
segura es que lo que hoy estamos
aprendiendo acá todos y ustedes lo que
están aprendiendo en la universidad
adventista del plata a través de un té
de c's
uniendo los puntos hacia atrás les hará
decir
guau ya sé el porqué salir sorteado para
estar acá
hoy estamos uniendo los puntos en el
futuro nos conectarán muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]